Donald Trump launched his presidential
campaign by warning that America had
become a dumping ground for immigrants
and that Mexico in particular was
sending criminals and people with lots
of problems they're bringing crime
they're rapists and some I assume are
good people his presidency has been
marked by anti-immigrant rhetoric in the
summer of 2019 president Trump previewed
sweeping immigration raids tweeting that
next week ice will begin the process of
removing the millions of illegal aliens
who have illicit ly found their way into
the United States that culminated in
August when Immigration and Customs
Enforcement agents conducted one of the
largest worksite immigration raids in US
history arresting nearly 700 chicken
plant workers in Mississippi on
suspicion of working illegally the raids
which were conducted jointly with the
Department of Justice left young
children separated from their parents
and marked a new front in the Trump
administration's attacks on undocumented
immigrants the Trump administration has
defended the actions saying they'd been
planned for over a year and arguing that
the workplaces were exploiting
undocumented workers are these raids
just for show just Trump's
anti-immigrant rhetoric actually
increase asylum seekers and what's the
connection between Obama era immigration
raids and Trump's I sat down with
Darland
a reporter with ProPublica to discuss
these questions and more so the first
thing I want to do is just ask you what
was it that happened in Mississippi tell
us a little bit about what these raids
represent sure so the Immigration and
Customs Enforcement and this was an
operation that was actually led by the
kind of Special Operations Division of
ice Homeland Security Investigations
which is separate from the kind of
run-of-the-mill deportation agents
enforcement and removal operations that
people often think of when they think of
ice uh they are responsible for some of
these bigger investigations into kind of
workplace immigration enforcement and
teams led by HSI agents targeted several
different agricultural processing plants
in Mississippi some of which were coke
foods some of which were owned by
smaller operators and kind of descended
upon them barring both regular search
warrants and like civil administrative
warrants which allowed them to arrest
people on suspicion of being
unauthorized immigrants
and you know swept through so got a
bunch of people who weren't able to
produce papers at that point held them I
many of these people have since been
released kind of pending you know they
were given a court date they were given
ankle bracelets they're now officially
in the deportation system some of them
are still being held but in total we're
looking at a higher number of arrests in
a single day than we've ever seen with a
workplace rate in the past and these are
this is a genre of raid that can often
result in several hundred people being
arrested but going all the way up to six
hundred in you know just a few targeted
locations is something we've never seen
before so the Trump administration has
been previewing these raids for months
right these were not entirely unexpected
so tell us a little bit about that put
these in context people there were
people who were worried that these raids
were coming right so I would actually
distinguish between these and the kind
of rates that people were worried about
there's generally a vast reaction to
anything Donald Trump says that implies
that people are gonna start getting
rounded up and deported ah those that
kind of that has a chilling effect in
communities whether or not people are
unauthorized or not you know even green
card holders can sometimes be worried
about going outside but usually the fear
there is ice agents going door-to-door
like in neighborhoods there have been
some raids like that under say the Obama
administration did some of them late
Bush and Obama but the kind of
neighborhood sweeps that people really
really freaked out about are not
necessarily what this was this was a
separate operation that it came out
after the fact had been kept so closely
that he the white house may not have
even known about it uh so when Trump was
tweeting these things earlier this
summer there had been some
back-and-forth consternation among
immigration officials about whether
having so much advance notice of raids
was going to make it harder for agents
to go door to door and so there's there
was a little bit of backbiting about oh
you're making it harder for law
enforcement to do their jobs not
directed at the president directed at
other people who had said the same
things the President had said so during
the Bush administration we saw workplace
raids that were like this we saw
immigration raids under President Obama
but not
targeted at specific workplaces in the
same way is that right right what the
Obama administration would do it was
what we're often dismissively called
paper rates right they would do audits
they would tell an employer okay we're
going to like over the next several
weeks check the employment status of
everyone you tell us as an employee and
you know if you have some people who you
don't think are authorized you should
ask them to produce some documents right
now and you know that often gave the
employer the opportunity to quietly fire
people so that they wouldn't get in
trouble but that was that strategy was
aimed at you know in theory the law
being enforced here is that it's illegal
to employ someone without authorization
it's a it's criminal to employ someone
with that authorization you can't work
in the u.s. without work authorization
but that's not a crime in the same way
it is a crime to employ someone so the
the Obama model was okay we're going to
use civil fines because that's the
appropriate response to somebody
employing someone who they shouldn't be
employing rather than rounding these
people up and arresting them for having
been employed the Trump administration
takes the same approach to this that the
Bush administration did which is the
real value of this is as it it turned
right you get a lot of press coverage
for sweeping down and just into
somewhere you make an example of some
people and a lot of other you know
would-be employers and employees both
for thinking in the back of their heads
gee I should be careful I shouldn't you
know I should maybe quit my job and move
back or I should maybe care a little bit
more about screening my employees
because I don't want this kind of thing
to happen to me and that's something
where the big theatrical raid does a
whole lot more damage than an i-9 audit
this was in many ways at a media event
designed for media coverage and so I
wonder if you can sort of help us
understand this especially relative to
President Obama relative to President
Bush it isn't a lot of this just for
show isn't it just to say well look
we're taking action and Trump believes
that immigration raids helped him
politically I definitely think that the
Trump administration has done a lot more
immigration enforcement force show than
kind of baseline everyday immigration
enforcement that's not necessarily
because they're choosing not to it's
to a large extent it's because they
can't the actual rate of deportations
under Trump is lower than you would
expect to be certainly a lot lower than
it would than it was under the first
term of Obama but that's a lot of that
is because fewer people are coming into
the u.s. than were inside the mid-2000s
and those who are unlike the people who
were coming in during Obama's first term
are largely families and people who are
seeking asylum so it's difficult to
deport them immediately which is why the
Trump administration complains about
loopholes all the time so the ability to
just kind of turn people around without
spending a lot of money and deport them
isn't really there what ice has done
instead is detain a lot of people spend
a lot of money on detention and then do
some of these kind of big flashy
enforcement actions on the work force on
the workplace side you know a couple of
things that they then advertise as these
big multi city sweeps I do think that
when it comes to immigration enforcement
things that are just for show aren't
ever just for show by which I mean they
are for show but it's not just to like
prove it to the base right the base
often doesn't even isn't even aware of
this stuff that's why during the Obama
administration when there were plenty of
enforcement actions you know the
Republican base didn't necessarily was
was saying that he should be impeached
for not securing the border that kind of
thing the target for whom the stuff
that's just for show really does matter
is immigrants themselves and you know
going way back to even before Trump was
elected but certainly the first days of
his administration when he and other
officials were going around saying if
you're here in the US illegally you
should be afraid you should be looking
over your shoulder there's been a large
strain of kind of deterrence through
fear in their strategy that they feel
that people were allowed to get too
comfortable during the Bush and Obama
administrations and that if they can
just make it seem plausible enough that
people will get deported that that might
lead them to either you know self deport
or very least to like not encourage
family members to come join them so the
goal here is to send the message to
potential immigrants to that it's a bad
idea to corrupt right across the border
and we don't know if that's working no I
mean it's always this is always a bank
shot at best right there is actually
some really suggestive evidence evidence
that under the Obama and early Trump
administration's that the number of
apprehensions that when there were
crackdowns when say President Obama
instituted family detention in late 2014
or when when Trump came into office in
early 2017 you do actually see dips in
the number of people who are apprehended
crossing into the u.s. and so there
really is a plausible argument there
that people are when they're worried
about a crackdown and enforcement
they're not likely to come in but it
looks like that's a wait-and-see kind of
thing it's not a oh well we're
permanently not coming it's a well we
don't really know what's gonna happen
and so we better kind of hold hold off
for a bit
what there's been suggestive evidence of
and this is something that no one's been
able to nail down yet but it's something
that I and other reporters have heard a
bunch from people who are working
directly with migrants kind of coming
through Mexico and up into the u.s. is
there's a certain sense out there that
because Trump is going to crack down
because he keeps threatening to like
close the border entirely or keeps
threatening but he's going to do this or
the other thing next that it creates an
opportunity for smugglers to say well
this is your last chance you'd better
get in now we're offering special prices
you'd better come through before it's
too late and so it may actually be Excel
or be accelerating the rate at which
people come by making them feel like
well eventually it's probably for the
best for me to come up there and this is
my last chance before Trump shuts it all
down so the more that Trump cracks down
on immigration the more immigrants are
likely to view it as a limited time
offer that they need to get in on now
before it's too late
well certainly the more that Trump kind
of threatens something in the near
future and doesn't necessarily specify
when that is and continues bumping that
down the road like when he was
threatening to shut down the border with
Mexico earlier this year when he was
briefly threatening to shut down
Guatemalan immigration earlier this
summer there's definitely a way in which
Trump's particular kind of
elevation does encourage this sort of
thing I want to talk a little bit about
people who are trying to come here to
work legally
and this one of the big arguments you
hear from conservative immigration
skeptics is well these people who are
here working illegally should get in
line follow the rules and you know and
come here legally and they could do that
that isn't always the case and
especially when we're talking about the
sort of low-skilled year-round workers
who work at places like the chicken
processing plants that were raided last
week can you tell us a little bit about
the underlying system what's it like if
somebody actually wants to try and come
here and play by the rules follow the
immigration laws and and get a permit to
work legally sure I mean for one thing
if you're trying to work in the US
legally you don't just go you just don't
send in an application yourself and say
hey I would like to work please find
someone to hire me it has to be going
through your would-be employer which
creates a lot of dynamics that don't
necessarily bit don't necessarily favor
the people who are trying to come and
work also means that in practice the
people who are hiring the workers aren't
necessarily the employers one of the
employers at this at their plants that
were raided last week said that they
weren't involved in hiring that's
something that often happens you have
this kind of level of disconnect what
often ends up happening is that people
who are here on other visas are instead
being told are being instructed to work
so certain kinds of student and tour and
travel visas are often subjected to this
so there's this whole like murky
demi-monde of technically they're legal
but they're not necessarily working
legally and all of that assumes that you
can like get in touch with the right
person and be brought over to work to
begin with you can't because you can't
just from your village in Guatemala say
hey by the way I would like to go you
know I would like to come work on your
farm the process that actually exists
for bringing people which assumes oh
there are people from outside who we are
going to get hire legally bring in and
then send back doesn't actually reflect
the way that people tend to work which
is they are coming to the US and then
they're gonna find a job once they're
here this sounds like it has a pretty
big impact on the labor market
what's this like for employers but also
what's this like for consumers the
especially when we're talking about the
agricultural industry which has been
where a lot of the highest profile rates
have been there was one high-profile
raid of a bunch of 7-eleven franchises
in 2018 where very few workers were
actually apprehended but that was that
was an outlier there's been a little bit
more interesting in kind of these
franchise raids under Trump but
generally the places that are targeted
for these big rates are agricultural
processing plants and that's the sector
where no one can really speculate what a
labor force without unauthorized
immigrant labor or without immigrant
labor period would look like because
it's just we've never seen it before
it's there there have been special
agricultural visa provisions you know
there still are but there that's kind of
been the back backbone of the labor
force since the 20s there are plenty of
kind of political structures in place
because agricultural labor is the
quintessential Americans won't do it
there have been some really interesting
investigative journalism pieces about
just how horrible the conditions on
these floors are they're not the kind of
job that people will necessarily take
for the kind of wages that you can pay
someone who isn't authorized to work
here and so the ceiling for how much it
would cost consumers to be buying goods
at the end of this if you're assuming
that everyone is being hired competitive
rates from within a market limited to
u.s. citizens if you're assuming you
know 100% compliance with the entire
other suite of regulations is just it's
kind it's it's unfathomable because it's
just so I mean it would just be such a
radical change and it would probably be
just so astronomically high in terms of
prices that you just you'd see a massive
distortion of the of the market like for
everything that people were talking
about with when we were talking about
shutting down the border with Mexico of
oh the avocados oh all of the imports
that we're dealing with first it's a lot
more than a virus right exactly well it
wouldn't be a lakatos it but it would be
a ton I mean the cost to
domestic meat prices would be ridiculous
because that require is like you know
chickens don't slaughter and debone
themselves that's something that we
really have relied on what we call
unskilled immigrant labor to do and it's
just that it turns out that in practice
hour by hour day by day it's a demanding
enough job that quote-unquote skilled or
not most people who aren't already doing
it aren't particularly well equipped so
this is obviously no fun for the
immigrants who are involved it's not
great for consumers it is certainly a
burden on employers and I want to
actually ask you about the employer
aspect of this Koch Foods issued a
statement saying well you know we've
tried to be in compliance we were
actually an early adopter of eve Arif I
II verify is of course probably the
biggest single policy response that
conservative anti-immigration activists
push in terms of in terms of saying well
we want to stop people at workplaces and
yet the states that have tried Eve Arif
I find extremely high rates of false
positives they find that the databases
are very difficult what is what do these
the fact that these raids are happening
at places that have adopted e-verify
early and are brag and are saying that
this is part of that they are complying
with these rules what does that say
about this about e-verify as a policy
and about its effectiveness the argument
the way that this tends to get defended
by the champions of e-verify is that
true e-verify has never been tried
essentially right and we have seen an
admittedly slight but still present
decline in a verify error it's over the
last decade but you're right we're still
looking at a world where employers who
are egregious enough in violating the
law that you know the Homeland Security
Investigations team decided that they
were going to make it you know make an
example of them aren't necessarily
correlate with the expressed willingness
to follow the law that he verify shows
in practice what this ends up meaning is
that employers get let off the hook
liability wise a little bit right
because as long as they're running
people through the e-verify system there
was one case in the search warrant where
a woman had tried to present documents
for work authorization and those
documents had been rejected and then she
comes back three weeks later with a
different set of identity documents goes
to the same HR person and they go
through and so it if you're using you
verify well those documents were
legitimate this person who's authorized
to work in the United States this is
fine it does make it a little bit more
it it allows employers to say well we
are doing our best to comply with the
law instead of kind of having a common
sense you know maybe you shouldn't be
allowing the same person to present two
sets of documents if you if enforcing
immigration law is important to you kind
of thing so you verify adds bureaucratic
complexity while allowing employers off
the hook and not making life better for
anybody else final question here for you
immigration is just so complicated in
terms of politically and culturally and
it often gets talked about in pretty
reductionist ways either more immigrants
are good or more immigrants are bad we
need more if they're breaking the law
what's the biggest single thing that you
as an immigration reporter who have
covered this for years what's the
biggest single thing that you think
people are missing from the immigration
debate I was in right now and this has
changed over time but right now there's
a certain assumption that people are
either legitimate refugees who are
fleeing some particular form of
persecution or they are just coming to
work and the reality is that people are
never just coming to people are never
just settle you in another country for
one reason right there might be one
specific thing that makes them decide
that it's the right time but they're
coming they they may want to work they
may be coming because they're worried
about they're not worried about their
own safety but they're worried about the
safety of their children there may be a
particular threat that they're fleeing
which may itself might be at the hands
of the government might be at the hands
of criminals might be something between
the two if people were just lumps of
Labor going back and forth it would be
much easier to retain the legal work
system that we have right now which kind
of assumes the people will be here for a
couple of years and then they'll go back
that's not how people work they you know
integrate into communities they put down
roots and so because you can't easily
isolate why people are moving or why
they're staying
it makes the whole system much harder
does
thank Darland is an immigration reporter
at ProPublica alright thank you so much
for joining us thank you